All right welcome everyone to this brief
webinar on the HTTPS protocol and Some
changes coming to NCBI web services.
my name is Eric Sayers i'll be talking
to you for a few minutes today about
what these changes are and what you can
expect and what you should do.
i'm here with my colleague peter cooper
who will be monitoring the questions
during the webinar and we'll try to get
to as many of them as we can. So we're
going to be talking about today are Some
upcoming changes to the way that
NCBI receives web service requests and
that primarily has to do with a
protocol called HTTPS which is
essentially secure HTTP. it's Something
that has been around for Some time and
it's becoming more popular for a variety
of reaSons; we'll talk a little bit about
what Some of those are. So what we're going to
try and do this afternoon is talk about
why we're doing this, because we have to,
this is a federal mandate for all
websites maintained by the federal
government;
Some of the benefits that we get from
using HTTPS; and then what's actually
happening at NCBI in particular
and what would be the consequences for
you or your users or customers that are
using Software products that you're
making, etc., and perhaps most interesting
to you, what should you do
now what do you need to do to respond to
these changes
what can you expect in the future and
then Some details.
So I'm going to talk very generally
about this, i'm not going to get into a
lot of technical detail.
we're going to have Some additional web
pages that will be going up very Soon
hopefully this week that will describe
more of the detail of what you might
need to be aware of, and i'll give you of
course Some contact information at the
end if you do have additional questions,
that you can get in touch with us.
So the reaSon why we're doing this is
because we were told to by the office of
management and budget.
this is a federal office that controls a
variety of things, but does supervise the
web presence of the federal government.
You can find out more about this
going to https.cio.gov at the top of
this page.
and it talks to you about the HTTPS only
standard that is now being rolled out
throughout the federal government. and
this was an announcement that was made
actually about a year ago in june 2015
that all federal agencies must make all
of their current existing websites and
services available and accessible
through HTTPS only protocols
by the end of this calendar year, by
December 31st, 2016.
So that's the challenge, that's the
mandate that we have and So that is the
reaSon why these changes are coming
about.
and just FYI of course this means that
any other government website that you're
dealing with is going to have to do
these same changes as well, So it
certainly is not limited to NCBI or NLM or NIH or anything like that.
why are we doing this, why is the
government and many many other private
enterprises switching to HTTPS?
Well for a large number of reaSons only a few
of which i've outlined here.
HTTPS encrypts all of the web traffic
between the server and clients So you
now have an encrypted transfer of
information which gives you a heightened
privacy and security.
So using HTTPS provides not just privacy
and security but a consistent level of
privacy and security across all federal
websites, all of the data that is
transferred during these transactions
maintains its own privacy and it
prevents various kinds of attacks. So it
protects, it prevents, for example, unknown
websites or web sites that are trying to
hack into various sites from masquerading
as a federal site. So it protects the
public from other sites that are trying
to pretend that they might be NCBI or NLM.
It alSo prevents the injection of
malware into web traffic So if Someone
was to intercept web traffic between the
server and the client then they could,
under HTTP, inject code potentially into
that traffic and the user wouldn't be
aware of that, and that malware would
appear to have come from the trusted
site that they're trying to get
information from. This is an obvious
problem. HTTPS does eliminate many of
those kinds of concerns.
There's a variety of other reaSons that
you might explore on the web about HTTPS
but those are a couple of the
ones that make the most impact.
So what's happening at NCBI? there's a
couple of things.
So in September, at the end of september
if you have a GET or HEAD request, and
i'll talk a little bit about what those
are in a minute,
those are going to be redirected to
HTTPS if they come over HTTP.
So an example there is, if you load a
PubMed article over HTTP after september
30th, that URL will be
automatically redirected to HTTPS and
then the same URL. So the protocol will
be switched automatically for you.
So if you are accessing NCBI using a web
browser you don't have to do much at
all, this will happen automatically.
You might see a variety of these
little icons as a green lock icon in
some browsers, other icons that indicate
to the user that you are now over a
secure transaction, a secure session,
HTTPS. But that's essentially all that
you probably would notice. So not much
has to be done if you're simply
accessing NCBI over the web.
many API request also will not have
problems with this if they are simply
providing get requests or head requests,
which basically means a URL.
So you're using the E-utilities or
something like that and it's simply a
URL that you're posting and that will
automatically get redirected to a HTTPS.
But if you are using HTTP POST and
you're providing the request, and these
are mainly again for api users like the
E-utilities,
those will be rejected after September
30th with the status 403,
they simply cannot be converted to HTTPS
if they're submitted over HTTP.
So if you have processes that are
submitting requests using HTTP POST, it's
a problem and it needs to be changed so
that those can be done over HTTPS.
that's one of the major things that we
see as a potential problem for
developers and users out there, so that's
one to be aware of.
So the consequences if you're only using a
web browser, again you probably don't
need to do anything, right, or if you
have clients that are simply using or
accessing NCBI web pages / browsers
it's not a big deal, this will
automatically redirect. But i would
recommend if you link to us, if you have
web pages that do have links to NCBI,
change them to HTTPS links in your
HTML code. It's just better practice and that
way there's no redirection that needs to
happen, but it's not a requirement, if you
have HTTP links, they will be redirected
for you.
Most web browsers again will handle
these 301 redirects elegantly and it's
not a problem. If you are using an API, so
these are the E-utilities or could be the
blast URL API any other API that NCBI
provides, your request may fail after
september 30, and in general it's going to
be hard for us to predict all the
different kinds of failures that may
happen.
It depends a lot on how you have set up
your API calls, but we know that if
you're using HTTP POST you will have
problems.
So again as I said that's the thing to
worry most about.
it's possible that the mechanisms that
you're using to call the api's may not
handle 301 redirects properly so the
best thing to do is not even risk the
redirects but just change the protocol,
which we'll talk about in just a moment.
Those are the things to be most
concerned about.
So what should you do? - change the
protocol.
If you are accessing any NCBI
website
or any NCBI service or any API calls to
NCBI over HTTP, change the code protocol
to HTTPS. And all you have to do is just
replace HTTP with HTTPS, that's it right,
all of the other parts of the URL stay
the same.
You should know that all web services,
right, our web services online, pubmed
blast, all of the sequence databases, all
of entrez, all of the web pages as well
as all of our APIs, the E-utilities,
blast URLAPI, everything works over HTTPS
today.
So there's no reason you can't change in
five minutes just do it now.
All right, so everything works, there
shouldn't be a problem, and just switch
it immediately and start to use HTTPS.
Now we understand that that is not
possible for everyone. It is going to take
some time to update code bases,
other kinds of software packages that
might be out there,
that's why we're trying to get the word
out as quickly as we can before the
september 30th deadline. now you might be
asking yourself, why September
30 vs December 31st? The federal deadline is
is December 31st. NLM's internal
deadline is September 30th, so we're
trying to get this done early so that we
can fix problems before the federal
mandate takes effect.
So one thing that you can do if it's not
possible to change all of your code
before that time, or you're not sure how
much of a problem you might be in, we
have set up some test servers. So i put
the URL to these test servers on the
screen.
these are currently live and you can
direct traffic over HTTP to these
servers and test your code.
So if you get a return from these
servers you're okay, right. So your
code is handed to redirect properly.
that's not to say that you should not
change to HTTPS. these redirection
servers will not be up there
indefinitely.
these are a crutch essentially to help
you test now and they will be going away
at the end of the calendar year when we
cannot accept
HTTP requests anymore. But these are
things that you can use now to see how
things work. So if you are accessing a
web page for example you can use the
first one, over http colon slash slash
https.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
So than any other URL that you would
normally have as going to www you can
now go to https.ncbi and
test. If you're accessing E-utilities,
right there is https://eutils-redirect, right.
So simply place that URL instead of
eutils.ncbi and then your normal URL
and if that works
you're good you're in good shape, right.
blast-redirect,
that's for the blast URL API. So those
are three test servers that are alive
right now and you can begin testing. So i
highly recommend that you try those out
if you have any questions about whether
or not your code might work or not.
So those are two things, change it if you
can change it as quickly as you can to
HTTPS, everything, search-replace just get
it done.
Two, if you have questions try these
tests servers and see what's going on.
now very soon we are going to be
releasing some more details about this
that will be available on the web. i'm
going to show you what these pages will
look like. I
hope they're going to go live this week
and then you'll be able to look at them
directly. there is a page that will
provide for guidance,
the link to that page is at the top of
the screen it's not live yet but it will
be.
there's also a develop page, an API
page, that is currently live on our site
that is going to be updated with links to
that new page giving you all of those
guidance details.
So i'm going to show you what those
pages are now. before i leave this slide
I just want to again emphasize that
we're here to help if you have
questions about this, if you're concerned
about this write to info@ncbi and please
describe as much as you can what your
situation is and will try to give you
some good advice about how you can
proceed to accommodate these changes. So
on the NCBI homepage there is a develop
link.
I've circled it here in red. that is a
page that we have designed particularly
for developers, people who are using our
APIs, our toolkits, to build software.
it's a really good page know about. if
you don't know about it
hopefully you do now. it's a good page to
advertise to friends and colleagues who
want to keep track of what's going on at
NCBI regarding toolkits, api's etc.
clicking that link when the new pages go
out, again i will emphasize these are not
live right now, but these will be coming
live,
there's going to be a link, you can see
it up in the upper right, NCBI goes
HTTPS-only starting September 30, get
more details. And click that thing it's
going to take you to this page that has
a lot of details on it.
Also, on this develop page and on the
live version of this page, there is a
link to api, so there's a separate API
page. it has details about various of our
APIs. it also has the same ad over here,
it will have that ad, which will get you to
this page. So i'll show you that new page
now and again most of what's on this
page I've already told you, so there's
not a great deal of information here
except some links, a little bit more
discussion, but the bottom line stuff
that we already talked about is
essentially what this page is trying to
show. A couple of things on the page, we
have tried to be in contact with a
variety of services biojava, biopython,
bioperl, etc. Many of these organizations
are aware that these changes are
occurring.
Many of these libraries are already
working fine, but you can track those
issues there. So we're continuing to
try and be aware of the communities that
need to update their code.
Again please contact us if you have
questions about this or or other
information that you'd like us to be
aware of. If you keep scrolling down on
this page is a few other points i just
wanted to highlight and again you got
this information and the powerpoint
slides you can take that and take a look
at it. Again after September 30th
everything is going to either be
redirected or rejected, so it's either
going to be redirected to HTTPS or it's
going to be an error condition. So those
HTTP POST requests, for example, are going to
get 403 forbidden codes,
alright. So that's a real issue, so please
be aware of that. Again,
check your API stuff, just check it, it needs
to be tested so that you make sure that
it's actually going to work after the
redirection and after the https-only world
that we're going to be in in 2017.
So when you look down here again these
test servers are detailed and discussed
in the little table there.
I've already told you about those
so there's not a lot of new information
there, but those are set up for your
benefit.
All right, so that's basically what i have
to say.
So do the tests, do the changes, please
let us know if you have questions about
it or any other concerns.
So I'll be quiet at the moment. Let Peter
know, let the question pod know if you have
questions about this and we'll
discuss.
[Peter Cooper] Okay, i answered many of
them by typing
there's a couple that i didn't answer.
I'm not sure I completely understand
some of them. One of them is, you want to
know if the test servers will internally
switch them over to HTTPS. i'm not quite
sure what that means maybe you have a
better idea what that means.
[Eric Sayers] So what the test servers do and you can you can try this out just in a web
browser, is they simply do the
redirection for you,
alright. And so it simulates what will
happen after September 30th. So I'm not
exactly sure precisely what you might mean
by internal redirection, but if you
mean internal to NCBI, yes.
So the HTTP request will come in to us,
we will redirect that to an HTTPS
equivalent and send that response back
to you.
So if your code is not able to handle
the redirect that will fail. If you are
able to handle, see and handle that
redirect, then it will be fine.
Right now there are no redirects
happening so you can submit
HTTP request to the eutils and blast
and they'll function normally.
They'll just come back to you as standard
status 200s, but once September 30
happens, that will no longer be the
case, you'll be redirected. And so to
simulate that redirect, point something
towards those test servers and you'll
get the same 301 redirect that
will happen after September 30.
[Peter] Okay, we have another question about
proxy servers that automatically change
the url. [Eric] We are looking into some of
these now.
My best advice is to do the testing. So if
you have a proxy server, try and submit
those requests to these test servers and
see what happens.
And let us know if there are challenges
that you have with that
or you're not getting things to work. We
have already been in contact with ez
proxy. Those discussions are ongoing
right now. Se should be able to get
something worked out where you'll have
appropriate certificate set up for ez
proxy to work. If that's something, or
other proxy services like that, are
concerns for you, please let us know and
we'll give you some additional guidance.
[Peter] Okay we have one more thing and I'm not
sure we can really address this in the webinar,
but i just will put it out there.
So somebody has requested that, they
wonder if it's possible for us to extend
our deadlines, since the federal mandate
is december, because they have software
and they can change their code but their
customer support might not get
it out to the people in time. And I don't
know if we have any, if we can comment on
that or not, but I'll let you decide
on that one.
[Eric] So if you read this document that I have
up there on the screen, there is a little
part of it that talks about how after
September 30th we may open up some
blackout periods or something like that,
where we'll stop doing the redirect for
a little temporary time period, and we will
publicize what those time periods will
be. We realize that folks are trying to
change software. This is a challenge,
it's a little bit of tight timing, we
appreciate that. Part of the reason for
the September 30th is just to make sure
that everyone is aware that problems
exist.
So if you know that there's going to be
a problem you can try and get changed
before december 31st. So if you have
software that really looks like you're
not going to be able to change it before
the end of the year please let us know.
We'll try and work with you.
We do plan to have some open windows
between, you know, in October through
December, where we might relax the
redirect from time to time,
alright, just to make sure that people
can confirm the things are working.
So if you do have concerns let us know,
we can't help you if we don't know, but
if you do let us know we'll try and work
with you to see what we can do.
[Peter] Eric, I was paying attention to the
question pod, so this page that you
showed, is there URL to this, is there a
link on one of the slides?
The one here at the end. [Eric] yes there is a URL
let me go back up in the slides here.
[Peter] Somebody asked to see that again. [Eric] So on
this slide, and again this will be
something that will be available to you, it's
available on the ftp site now from
the materials link. The top URL is the
URL to that page. Again, it's not live
right now but hopefully this week it
should be up.
So, www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov slash home slash develop slash https dash guidance.shtml. So that's
where it should be.
You guys are getting a little bit of
advance warning today with the webinar.
So i tried to copy most of that page on
to the powerpoint so at least you can
get a sense of what you're going to see.
[Peter] Eric, can you show the NCBI homepage and
just sort of how to get to the webinars and
courses page, because I think a lot of
people want these slides and although we
had the link at the beginning, it might
be a little difficult to get that. So if we
can just show them how to navigate.
they'll be in the archives section by tomorrow.
[Eric] From the NCBI homepage go to learn, which is
over here on the right,
then on the learn page scroll down
underneath the image, there's going to be
a webinars and courses link.
This is a general link that takes you to
a page that summarizes all of the
different webinars and courses that we
have going on.
So right now if you scroll down you'll
see the one that you're watching right
now, on July 27. And there are no
materials links at the moment but very
soon after this webinar, Peter was
indicating this will migrate to the
archived webinars and courses tab, which
is up here at the top of the table. i'll
go ahead and go there now just to show
you. For example, that yesterday
there was another webinar.
There's a link over here to materials. So
that link materials takes you to our ftp
site where you can download the
PowerPoint PDF of the presentation. So
that's where it will be. Another place if
you want to get to it right now which
you can
because it's on the ftp site right now,
if i go back up to the very first slide
here,
although this isn't as fun to copy down
but http colon slash slash bit.ly slash
2 lowercase a lowercase q 6 lowercase h uppercase
R uppercase R; that URL will take you to
the ftp site into the directory where
the slides are.
[Peter] I just sent that link out to the entire
audience in chat, i'm not sure what that
looks like on your end but I think you
should see it. Also Eric,
is there, that page that's not live
yet,
do you know where that's going to be
linked? Can you show them where that
will appear? [Eric] So let me go back to, what
I'll do is I'm just going to step
through the slides one more time.
I think this would be a little bit
easier just because I highlighted some
things. Here's the NCBI homepage. Where it
will be is, if you go down to develop,
right. So this is again the page that we
have for developers, the API stuff. You
click that link
what you will see once the page is live
is this page. Now, this page is live right
now, but it does not have this ad
up in the upper right, and HTTPS-only
is not visible currently. When the page
goes out later this week
this ad will appear. Click that and
you'll get to the page that we've been
talking about with all the details on it.
[Peter] So the recording, someone else asked
about the recording. The recording will
be uploaded and that'll take, it
depends on how long it takes to get
captioning and things like that, but it
should be within probably a
week and a half or something like that.
It will be on our youtube channel.
Just look for ncbinlm and YouTube.
[Eric] All right, so i think what we'll do at this
point is close the webinar. We have some
other questions that have come into the
questions pod. We will be addressing those
and as we talked about in the beginning of
the webinar, we will put answers to those
questions up with the materials. So
you'll be able to see those.
So if you do have a question that
hasn't been addressed yet,
please check back with the materials.
And we'll send out some about additional
information just to remind you where all
of those things are, to all the
people who have attended. All right, thank
you very much and I'll be signing off.